the moon's an amazing object it's our
closest celestial neighbor
and yet it has been a mystery for
centuries
what's it made of how did it form
that's why the apollo missions were so
important because
if you don't have samples if you can't
actually take a piece of the moon and
study it in a laboratory
then it's just guesswork and so the
apollo
astronauts those brave individuals who
went and
landed on the moon collected samples and
brought them back to earth
gave us a scientific bonanza that we're
still
enjoying today that we're still learning
from today there's
so much we don't know about the moon and
without those precious samples
we would just be ignorant this is
houston radio check over
[Music]
all right you're used to mud and clear
hi i'm bob hazen i'm a mineralogist and
crystallographer
and i've been studying rocks and
minerals from earth and from the moon
for 50 years
this legacy of apollo when humans
first brought back samples from our moon
50 years ago is astonishing the
scientific insights it's given us
not just to the origin of the moon but
also the evolution
of our planet those incredible
astronauts and and they didn't know what
they were getting into they didn't know
whether they're going to be
landing on dust that they sank into when
they walked on the surface
they didn't know if they're going to be
landing on a rocky
field where the lander might have tipped
and maybe even
fell over there were all these dangers
that they didn't have but it worked out
and those very first astronauts were
able to bring back about 50 pounds
of rocks and soils that told us
things about the moon we never knew
before i tried to get a rock in here
so there were hand samples just chunks
of rock that neil armstrong just picked
off the ground and put in a bag
there were soil samples and by soil i
mean the lunar soil is really strange
it's comprised largely of of this
incredibly
fine-grained dust so fine that it's not
like any dust you've ever seen
the particles have electrostatic charge
they stick together like dust bunnies
and they get they cover everything if
you look at the old
astronauts suits you'll see that they're
gray because
they're covered with dust and you can't
just brush that dust off
it it in fact it sticks forever but also
embedded in those soils were lots of
fine-grained
minerals and so they sieved out the
finest particles
what was left was like this this
collection of
sand grains and that's what i studied
those sand grains are amazing you look
at them in a microscope and they're
every color of the rainbow there's
beautiful deep reds
ruby reds there's greens oranges
all colors indicating there's some
really interesting chemistry going on
and so when i first started studying
these samples i was able to study
samples from
apollo 12 and apollo 15 apollo 17
even some of the soviet union's luna
samples because the soviets also
returned a small amount
of minerals from the moon so
i looked at a microscope and i'd pick
out
really beautiful grain just a fraction
of a millimeter
but large enough that if you held them
in your hand you could actually see
those individual grains red greens and
yellow greens and green
greens and i would select them and i'd
do the chemical compositions
i would look at their crystal structures
and most importantly i'd measure the way
light
interacted with the crystals see here's
the trick
we wanted to understand what's the moon
made of
and it turns out it's made of things
that are very similar to the rocks and
minerals we find on earth
olivines and pyroxenes and feldspars the
things that make up
most of the rocks of earth's crust
but the moon samples were were in some
ways
different and we had to know
how different you measure the
composition and you then you see how
light interacts
but the more basic thing that was
discovered those moon rocks
they were eerily familiar
they looked like chunks of earth
how's that possible you have the moon
it's the separate object that's out
there
some people thought the moon was a
captured planet that
somehow went into orbit around earth but
we found no
the the moon is a piece of earth it has
the same
elements it has the same isotopes it has
the same minerals
it's different in cell ways but
basically it's the same
this then led to the proof of the idea
that the moon formed along with earth in
a giant collision
the idea you have an early planet earth
and it's the dominant object it's the
largest
gravitational object in our zip code of
the solar system
but there is a competitor a little bit
smaller
it's called thea the the goddess of the
moon
and and saya was competing for the same
orbital space but the smaller object
in these competitions always loses
so eventually earth and thea got too
close
there was a huge impact they as
completely obliterated just just
vanishes but earth is pretty much
affected too so earth
now becomes this entire molten sphere
hot glowing incandescent red hot rocks
it must have been spectacular from space
and and thea has all but obliterated
now thea had a metallic core it looks
like earth swallowed up most of that
core
but what's left over is what makes most
of earth that's the mantle type rocks
these are
rocks that have olivines and pyroxenes
these
these rocks that i was studying in the
lab and it turns out
my gosh the composition of those rocks
are essentially the same
so here's the model of the moon's
formation that came out of apollo
you have thea here you've got earth
there comes it smacks earth a little bit
off-center
everything just kind of smooshes around
everything's
molten it's just a big mess but most of
the mass goes back to forming the earth
earth doesn't change
all that much in its size and its
composition has a little bit bigger core
but a whole chunk of earth's mantle it's
like taking an ice cream scoop and just
kind of
scooping out a piece of mantle and
throwing it into space and that
coalesced is the moon and there's the
moon
which is essentially a big chunk of what
was earth's mantle and a little bit of
thea's mantle as well because everything
got mixed up
and that's the biggest single scientific
legacy of apollo the understanding that
moon and earth are intimately connected
in a way
that we didn't realize before it's just
so amazing and profound to find that out
but that was just the first level of
discovery and we've been continuing to
make discoveries for
the past 50 years before apollo people
wondered why is there no atmosphere why
is there no
ocean if if the moon forms so close to
earth
why do they seem so different why does
the moon seem bone dry
well the apollo rocks they helped
solve this question to a point
because when you look at those lunar
soils
one of the most dramatic things you see
are these tiny
gorgeous glassy spheres
they're volcanic spheres of that
were exploded out of the surface that
you have
lunar volcanism and that volcanism must
have been explosive and then what you
see
are these tiny spheres many of them are
green a deep
beautiful emerald green others orange
orange spheres that you sort of wonder
what causes that color
and because they're spheres
it means there must have been some kind
of explosion
and some kind of fluid vapor
water probably that caused that
explosion but
we don't see the water on the moon we
don't see minerals that contain
lots of water as you do on earth
so was there much water where did it go
the very first experiments people did to
answer this were to take those tiny
spheres and measure the water content
and it turns out there's just not that
much water in the spheres on average you
take a sphere that's a fraction of a
millimeter across
you analyze the entire sphere the total
amount of
water measured as hydrogen is just
simply not very large
but you have to look more closely
and experiments that were done by some
of my colleagues
revealed a real surprise if you take
those spheres you mount them in epoxy
cement
you carefully polish down the surface so
now you're just seeing
the inside that circular inside of an
orange or a green sphere
and you take a very sensitive instrument
called a nanoprobe
and you look at the hydrogen content as
you work as you march
across that sphere the surprise is at
the edges of the sphere
very very low water content but as you
go towards the middle
there's this huge peak much much more
water in the center of the sphere and
what that tells us is over the billions
of years that those spheres have been
exposed to the lunar surface
where the sun beats down where there's a
high vacuum
very gradually ever so slowly the
hydrogen seeps out the water seeps out
and when you measure the average amount
of water in one of those grains it seems
quite low
but if you take the very center point
where it's
farthest from the edges where you have
the highest water content
it reveals there's hundreds of parts per
million
water in those lunar volcanic rocks
and that's enough water to drive
explosive volcanism
it's enough water to tell us that
there's a lot more water on the moon
than we originally suspected so you see
we're still
learning from the apollo samples we're
still finding out new information as we
have
more techniques and i'll tell you there
are hundreds and hundreds of pounds of
lunar samples
still in texas in houston where they
have never been studied
they're still hermetically sealed
they're kept in a very cold environment
they're kept under nitrogen so they
don't change
and they're just waiting for the next
generation of analytical techniques to
come along for us to study
and learn even more
we have an immense crater on the far
side
of the moon it's 2500 kilometers across
it's the
largest impact object anywhere in our
solar system that we know about
and so that excavated deep into the
moon's surface
probably below the crust but then we
have additional
meteorites asteroids crashing down
excavating even deeper and so
much of the mantle of the moon has been
thrown out
onto the surface where we can study it
directly so this is a whole new thing
the far side of the moon holds pieces of
the moon's
mantle that tells us something about
the structure of the moon that we never
knew before in any case
that gives us an opportunity on the far
side to see geology that's different
than on the near side but we've never
been able to go there we're never able
to land
and it's only very recently in may
of 2019 that a chinese mission
that's the chang e4 mission landed on
the far side and was able to
analyze the soils and the rocks and they
found something really amazing
you see the moon is formed much like the
earth in layers
there's a relatively tiny core about 300
kilometers in diameter
that this very very thick mantle
they can tell that from seismic
measurements on the moon running seismic
waves sound waves through the moon and
seeing how that reflects
and a fairly thin crust but that thin
crust is 15 to 20 miles thick that's
thick enough that
the normal impact is not going to allow
you to
see the excavated mantle it will not
shower the surface with fragments of the
mantle
but it turns out on the far side of the
moon it's a different story with that
huge
impact and then additional craters
landing inside the big crater
you can actually excavate pieces of the
moon's mantle
and we've discovered that from that far
side mission just
in this year 2019 that
that far side is made largely of
pyroxene
and olivine two minerals that we think
are dominant in earth's mantle as well
so here's more evidence
that the moon's mantle is very similar
to earth
and i'll tell you what my favorite my
hope is my wishes i hope this happens in
my lifetime because
because this would transform our
understanding of planet earth you see
studying the moon is not just an
abstract thought we're really trying to
understand
ourselves where we come from how did
earth form
what can we learn about our planet
and the origin of life and the moon
may hold the key because
one of the things we're going to find
when we go back to the moon
one of the things we're going to find
when we have stations on the moon and we
have geologists exploring
roving the surface collecting more and
more rocks is we're going to find
fragments of the most ancient
earth earth meteorites
that landed on the moon think think
about that you have a giant impact
on the early earth it smashes the crust
it smashes the surface
fragments of earth are blown out into
space
and some of those are going to fall on
our moon
they're going to litter the surface and
when we find
those rocks they'll be more than 4
billion
years old they'll be the oldest rocks we
have ever seen from earth it will tell
us about our earliest history
how the oceans formed how the atmosphere
formed whether there was
life in those earliest times
and you say oh that just sounds like
science fiction that can't possibly be
true
but it turns out there was a recent
finding of a
meteorite from the moon
what's called a breccia a brechus lots
of tiny tiny fragments
of rocks from all over the surface of
the moon that came together and got
cemented together
and one of those fragments
looks like a piece of earth
so there's already this very tantalizing
hint that we have a piece
of ancient earth preserved in a
meteorite that came from from the moon
and if we go back to the moon we're
certain to find
bigger chunks chunks of earth i just
can't wait for that to happen
that's going to be a major finding it
will transform our understanding of the
history
of our planet in 1969
at that time of the landing i was an
undergraduate at mit
and it turns out my thesis advisor
because i stayed on for a master's
degree my thesis
advisor dave once was a scientist
who was revered in the field of
petrology so he understood rocks and how
they form
and so he was selected to be one of the
mission
scientists for apollo he was sent to
houston
when the samples came in he was
quarantined they actually quarantined
the samples because they didn't know
whether there might be some harmful
viruses or or some other
thing that was toxic so they put all
these scientists
in a locked room along with the
astronauts and they had to stay there
and for those two weeks they got to
study the samples and when dave once
came back to mit he came back carrying
those first lunar samples i can't tell
you how exciting this was i mean these
were pieces of the moon
no one had ever had pieces of the moon
and here was dave ones
walking into the 12th floor of the green
building on mit
flanked by two burly armed guards i mean
they had guns
in their in their holsters and they were
you know looking around and kind of
and all the grad students and we were
standing around watching dave
and he held a briefcase and he opened
the briefcase and these little vials in
this case
dave was transferring samples to other
laboratories
and what he had to do is take a little
vial of moon dust
and transfer it into smaller vials to be
given to different laboratories
well it turns out as i mentioned you
know moon dust is a very weird stuff
it's incredibly fine grained it's sticky
it holds together it's it's not even
like transferring
flour but when he when he tried to turn
the vial his hands were shaking a little
bit you know because he's got all these
people looking at him and he's got the
arm guards standing there
and his hands shaking and nothing's
coming out and he's tapping the vial
nothing comes out
trying to dump it onto a piece of
plastic
paper that would hold him and then
suddenly foosh all the stuff comes out
and there's this cloud of moon dust that
kind of rises and spreads around i mean
we're breathing the stuff
and and it's all over his fingers he's
got moon dust on his fingers and he
eventually transfers them into three
vials but on that glass
scene the sheet of paper that he used
they were actually day ones fingerprints
in moon dust
after the guards left we kind of took
the piece of paper and we had it framed
and mounted
there was no label on it you know you
weren't supposed to keep
samples of nasa owns them all but we we
kept them anyway
we kept a frame with dave once
fingerprints and moon dust that was my
my first recollection and i wasn't
studying the moon then
but a few years later i had the
opportunity to come to the carnegie
institution and my first job as a
scientist was to
extract tiny grains from these lunar
fines these very fine
sand-like grains the colorful ones the
reds and the greens and the
and the yellows and so forth and by the
way the way you pick up a sand grain
it's funny you have a needle
and in order to make a sticky you
basically brush the needle against your
nose because there's a little bit of oil
and then that
you can stick you can stick the needle
down and pick up an individual grain
and then transfer it to a glass slide
and then very carefully
document it measure its composition
measure its crystal structure measure
its optical properties
i did that for dozens and dozens of
grains and every time i look down the
microscope every time i move to grain
i was thinking my gosh this is a real
piece of the moon this was brought back
by
our astronauts this this is something
that no one in history has ever been
able to do before and now we've got this
treasure trove and we're learning from
it it was for
a young scientist it was it was amazing
opportunity
the apollo missions their importance
just
it can't be overstated because
they were a source of scientific
fascination of course but there also was
the political idea the the the whole
military the fact that we were in a cold
war with the soviet union and the soviet
union
got to the moon first they had a they
had a
lander on the moon many years before
apollo in in the mid 1960s and so
this race the idea that we could
actually send human beings
to the moon bring them back safely bring
back samples scientific treasure trove
and plant our flag and all these these
levels of meaning as a scientist though
for me this was
the scientific adventure how is the
quality of the tv
oh it's beautiful mike really is
oh geez that's great yes indeed they've
got the flag up now and you can see the
stars and stripes
so we had six successful landings we had
12 astronauts
walk on the moon and the last of those
harrison jack schmidt
he was an harvard graduate he was got
his phd in geology and he was the only
scientist
amongst those 12 men to walk
on the planet and it was amazing to hear
jack talk about it afterwards he'd come
to harvard he'd talk to us about
his experiences and his ideas and about
his ambitions to see the
human interaction with the moon continue
um
he was the one who was able to walk and
look at boulders and use a hammer
and and take specific rocks and and
bring them back
a more a larger number of samples and a
greater variety from apollo
17 because of jack schmidt's
participation
i'm looking forward to the day when we
have geologists living
on the moon for months at a time
exploring far and wide going to many
different types of areas
most of the apollo missions were landing
in the very smooth flat areas called
mares these maoris were basically seas
seas of lava seas of basaltic lava and
therefore very
flat it's the dark areas the moon when
you see it but there's also lunar
highlands those are the jagged mountains
a much more dangerous place to land and
so it wasn't the first choice of
of the apollo missions
the apollo missions taught us something
beyond
just a specific rock or mineral or
origin of a planet
it was an incredible integrated effort
where
you had scientists and engineers
the astronauts with their technical
training
but also their ability to fly these
incredible spacecraft
and it was an integrated approach that
also
showed that science is not just about
physics or just about chemistry
or just about biology and geology but
you have to understand
all of these fields together to
understand the evolution the origin
of planets of moons that's an incredibly
important insight that's true
today as well
[Music]
you